okay everybody I am really honored today
to have Nina kiri join me who plays Alma
on The Handmaid's Tale what is special
about this interview in particular is
that this is the first time having
someone on for a second time and it's
the right person because Nina was one of
the first people who actually came on my
show and I didn't have much of a
following so she gave me a chance before
nobody else and that just shows you the
type of person she actually is off
screen so have you talked to again how
are you doing today Nina thank you I'm
happy to talk to you and I'm happy to be
here but I'm good good good yeah and I'm
excited to talk to you because it seems
like in the past couple of us knows
there's been a lot of Alma and a lot of
just drama in that loaves and fishes
store which I feel like is almost home
base in a way I want to talk about in
the episode first where of Matthew
actually rats June out earlier in that
episode in loaves and fishes you're the
one who's always kind of pulling June
aside by saying certain lingos to like
make sure no one's catching on you guys
are chatting about other stuff but in
particular you say in that episode about
fruit cocktails being over there and
June even says like really and you're
like I'm not amazing at improv what I'm
wondering is do you think all my ever
connected how much of a mess up that
actually was because that really was
what started getting of Matthew kind of
on to them in that particular moment do
you think Alma kind of connects in any
way that that's started the boat to that
Martha being hung in that episode I
think that she's I'd I think the thing
about Juliet is that because everybody's
so separated into their own houses and
they only get to meet in these common
spaces I think there's a little bit of
dissonance between what what they think
they know what they think they're going
to give away and what they think they're
not going to give away does that make
sense like for example Alma is coming
into this situation she's had many of
these conversations with June she
of Matthew's weird and super pious but I
think that just like anybody she's
coming at it from her own knowledge her
own experience her own background so I
don't know how much she thinks that of
Matthew is on to all of them and how
what the repercussions of that could be
but I think that like she's doing what
they've always done and not I don't
think that she thinks that it's going to
end up being what it is right I'm not
you okay so in that kind of mindset that
you're explaining of Alma later on after
the next episode we had there was a huge
debate online and a lot of like even
from my take - it was hard to just
there's a lot to take in seeing kind of
the bullying of Matthew after the
handmaids kind of figure out that she
was the rat well from almost perspective
I mean no I'm gonna actually go with
this from Nina's perspective do you
think Alma was too harsh in that episode
especially with the crybaby a moment
with them all kind of ganging up on her
or did you feel there is some
justification there and from almost
perspective it makes sense like do you
do you side with her in a way well from
my own Nina's protective no I don't side
with what they did I think that again
from almost perspective it's you're in
this place you're in a completely you're
taken away from all your friends you're
in your own home you I think that you
start to rely on herd mentality to a
certain certain extent like you know I
don't think that any normal sane person
would be so cruel to someone but I think
about you know people in high school
people in group you get into this kind
of like spiral with everybody else and
everybody else is doing it and also you
start to see black and white really
right like finally and I think that
that's an example at least that's how I
interpreted it at the time because yeah
it was just like
you know this is insanely cool but I
think it starts from June being insanely
cool for because she's literally going
off a rocker and and then you know I
think we all kind of are
by this point in gilead and I think that
being in those situations and I think
that herd mentality is so much stronger
and I think that that's what pushes at
least alright but I think a lot of
people to do those things without really
having done that and also you know like
they have had these established
relationships with June before whereas
of Matthew from the way I saw it I
didn't know her very well she was she
had already been in the system while I
was still at the red centre you know and
all I know about her is that she's just
like had all these kids to them she
pious she's a breeder she's a part of
Gilead and then on top of that she does
these she ends up making these
casualties for people that are on my
side and on the side of the resistance
and so it's like you know any normal
person would be like you know that's not
cool but this is all extreme situation
and I think extreme situation breed
extreme hate and extreme reaction yeah
yeah I think that's awesome explanation
and it makes complete sense and yeah and
it kind of hits just that like you're
all victims you know and it's like no
one's it's like such a cruel world that
it's almost like the whole like cruel
Gilly ads fault in a way and you're all
just trying to do the best you can and I
think it's really eye-opening what makes
this season so strong and I want to ask
you to in the last week's episode
episode 10 called witness we learn a big
thing that Alma has a son Dylan who was
now named Josh and that he's blond and
that Alma's into the blondes because his
father was blond
did you like something this is like a
big reveal for Alma so for such a
mysterious character to the audience of
Alma I mean are you creating a backstory
in your head for this type of character
and were you kind of involved the
decision of like oh she has a son now or
like was that kind of brought up to you
like how does that like even come about
in a way
um ya know it's a really good question I
mean for me I think I because of the
nature of the way I've been on the show
and the way I've come to have this
character I it's been very much I hear
things and I have to interpret them and
there's been I've had some really great
discussions with the writers they always
come on set for at least a couple days
and it's such a nice moment everyone's
like oh my god yeah either the writer
here we can talk about things and it's
really nice to have that like connection
and be able to talk to them about their
character and about what's happening but
with Alma I had no idea that that would
be a thing the way that I had built my
character around her was that every time
I had found this new information about
her coming from an literally just
reading an episode I would add that to
the entire story of how I saw Alma and
it really helped me to to approach it
like I feel like the entire experience
with this show and the way that I've
approached my hair had been has been
very like I'm just going to put myself
in this situation based off of the
limited information that I know and work
off of what I have lines wise and
environment wide like I I just always
remember my first day on the first
episode of the first season and I had
really nothing to work off of other than
you know one quick like one-line
description of who Alma was right and I
I think that because of that I've
learned to slowly piece it together and
base it more off of what she's saying
and how she what she's surrounded by and
her reaction to that sounding like for
example in the first season reactions
were incredibly light compared to
everybody else's like in every situation
that you saw her everyone else had these
you know dark scared stressed-out tense
mhmmm faces and feelings and words and
then like the first second you see her
she's like laughing and smiling being
super creepily normal and that was like
a really great insight and ever since
and then you know
like ii like an episode of that season I
was talking to Bruce Miller the
showrunner and he was like man I love
that Elmas so why is she smiling why is
she know why in the first episode is she
the only person who has a big smile on
her face
and I was like I think it's really I
think it's really interesting so I think
I've worked off of building her mm-hmm
based on situations and based off of the
little snippets of information I can
find and for this specific episode when
we have that reveal about her backstory
I had no idea about that before I I saw
it when I read that episode and then I
kind of I kind of added to what I had
already thought about her um they found
when I heard that interesting so I'm
wondering - from speaking to Alma
herself you're talking about just to how
the audience perceives Alma and like
again the smiling and I think a big
thing people always say about Alma is
that compared to June where Jews can't
kind of chaotic and Janine's just very
like intense in her own ways but Alma's
like this rock I always feel like of
that group and there's like such
strength that comes from her and I I
wonder where do you think that might
come from and Alma like what where where
is that truth if that makes sense
I do think that especially after I found
out about the kid I think that she is
very young I think she is younger than
June I think she's younger than were and
from the beginning I kind of always saw
her the younger handmaid like she's in
her early 20s as opposed to early 30s
and once I found out about the kid I
thought to myself like this could
actually be a lot of solution.i as to
why she is the way she is you know like
she had this kid she's obviously younger
than them it's kind of been alluded to
before and maybe that has to do with why
she's so precise about what she's doing
because she has that youthful energy to
go to go that to go far in the
resistance but she's very collected and
precise about what she's doing
I think that that could be at least the
way I saw it due to you know having made
some mature decisions and having had
probably this kid when she was way
younger than most people are when you
have a kid because you know she didn't
have the kid in gear we had she had it
pre gilead meaning she had it probably
when she was either very like late teens
or early twenties I think that that
could I don't know that was kind of a
cool revelation for me I was like maybe
because I agree with you I do think
she's super precise to the point that
sometimes is like oh wow
like I thought Alma would be doing more
in the resistance and she didn't or you
know and it's like well maybe that's why
because she she's being extra careful
and that that was interesting to find
out about because it kind of gave
insight to that to what you're saying
about her precision yeah definitely and
I think that was really exciting to see
that and like giving Alma more like
InFocus again she's so the arts been so
mysterious which i think makes people
excited too because we've known her for
three seasons and as the actress of all
I mean compared to like you've been in
like a ton of films and I'm just like
seeing it as with films you're acting in
it and then that characters done you
know the story's wrapped up you move on
but you've been doing Alma for three
seasons at so many episodes and over a
span of years and I wonder like do you
get attached to the character and almost
like it's like you're you're protective
of it's like your baby so do you get
like is it deeper than just a role now
is it more like there's a connection for
Nina to Alma here and that even when you
find more information about her like
you're kind of nervous because you don't
want it to like maybe be tarnished in
your head I know I know what you're
saying I have to say I think I have more
of a connection to the entire show okay
like I don't know if I feel as I think
that Alma as a character like I love
that character and I know that that's
who I am in the show and that that's so
nice to get to come back to but even
nicer than that is coming back to
everyone who works on the show I I think
that I'm more of a people person in that
way and I have to say that so many times
her coming to life becomes much stronger
when she's surrounded by her peers so
like I feel like to me my favorite
moment and you know all of my moments
are always around other hand me and
usually they're around June and those
are always the most powerful because I
think that she's the type of character
who comes to life around other people
like she's she's super super social
she's always she's always talking she's
always gossiping she's always comes to
life with in social situations and I
feel like I'm like that too and so with
regards to both her that character and
the way I feel about her I think that
much of it is based off of her position
within a social situation does that make
sense yeah no totally and off of that I
mean if I was to ask you how much of
Nina Keary is in Alma like would it be
like no that that she's nothing like new
yours they're like oh yeah no I act like
that sometimes right do you feel that uh
yeah actually and I I have to say I
never been on a show for this long and I
think that when I when I've done filmed
when I do films and I'm like okay so
last year I did this film where the
character I played was extremely
different than me and I really worked
really hard on her because I you know I
was just kind of like holy [ __ ] oh my
god and and I did like weeks and weeks
of prep on it and on the shoot I
actually like and my director but didn't
let me speak to people and I honestly
didn't really for the first like two
weeks wasn't really close with the crew
wasn't close with other actors because I
knew how what I'm like and I learned
people so I will so I was just like I
really just can't associate right now
because I know I just don't want me to
creep into her anyway all that is to say
that was all my thing there are a lot of
things that I that I do that are similar
to her but I've had to consciously when
I come on set be like okay this is my
time to say hi to everybody to do it
everybody but I do I have to completely
tone it
and bring it back and come back to those
things and and this is why I said what I
said about her in social situations
because it's always really helped me to
sit in Gilead for a second before we
start shooting or while we're doing
rehearsal because it always centers me
and always gives me that opportunity
like this is where I am right now and I
have to say Lizzie is a huge factor in
that because she is such an incredible
actor that I when I'm in scenes with her
I'm just like okay this is where I am
great like she she just like brings me
back within the scene and that is always
really helpful to me but yeah it's a new
experience for me too and like just
because of the nature of it being we're
always in these social situations that
it is easy for me to sometimes be like
myself and then I I really have to take
a second and be there and be like no
this is not this is not fun and this is
not what's happening and especially
because the show has become really
special to everybody and and especially
me forgetting I'm from Toronto and I've
been there since the beginning so it is
it is easy to be like oh my god I'm here
like so relaxed I don't care I'm almost
too comfortable so I I have to say that
that yeah that's a good question because
I definitely have have to actively think
about that so I feel like to you know
anytime I see loaves & Fishes come on
the screen which is a lot in season 3 I
get excited then I know I was around the
corner and then I get more excited coz
anytime I see Alma I know there's gonna
be a big plot point and the plots gonna
move forward in some way we're gonna get
some cool information and I think the
whole audience always like when I go on
even The Handmaid's Tale reddit like
anytime I see anything about Alma it's
excitement like be like almost a bastard
yeah and I'm with that because I always
know something like there's like again
they ask that mystery the character too
but I'm wondering because loaves &
Fishes
is a lot in the season there's been a
lot of big scenes there with Alma are
you guys shooting this out of sequence
or are you shooting this in line with
the story and are you like doing this
all in like two days at that place or
like can you kind of explain that like
it
yeah yeah like do we use out location
shoot out the scene no we actually we
don't do it in sequence
there was actually um because Yvonne had
a child like in real life we actually
shot a lot of stuff before she came in
and then so that was like an interesting
way of shooting it this season where we
shot a lot of the episodes all every
part that she wasn't in which wouldn't
pertain to me anyways because you're
usually not in theme together but anyway
and then we shot everything with her so
the way it worked was I think all of the
loaves & Fishes scenes we did throughout
the year because there were so many
different ones and it's a it's a
location outside of Toronto that's like
an hour and a half away it's the store
that they remain in the ropes and fishes
but every time I'm there it's Rosanne
fishes and I don't know what happens
when we and it just stays well the
vision I actually have no idea but
that's really funny because there at
different time okay yeah cuz I feel like
loaves and fishes is coming like a
little bit iconic kind of like the
scoops of Hawaii and stranger things or
something like that words like I think
like pop-up stores of loaves and fishes
cuz you know I just feel I don't know I
think there is a situation you know I'm
like this is the pinnacle of that design
it's insane it's these like pastel color
these everything there's no writing on
anything it's really really cool to see
so I do am a fan yes really really cool
so now shifting gears from the serious
part of Handmaid's Tale to actually the
fun part it seemed like you guys always
have on set and I really loved your
Instagram there is a clip you shared of
you all dancing and you called yourself
that day the set choreographer and and
dad is like counting and you guys are
all dancing when you're all lined up how
did the keys explain how this happened
or what exactly was going on
yeah so um for a while now me and my
friends are here who is also on the show
we always hang out together and she
plays Breanna and we for a long time so
cool to do dance but maybe even just
doesn't mean you and our costumes it
just seemed like the thing to do we're
all in an outfit together like it just
got screams like choreographed dance and
so then I always mean about for a while
and on this one day it was the day that
we shot a crybaby the crybaby scene was
Matthew and it was a really long day we
were in this place for a long time all
sitting there I think everyone was a
little bit after scenes like that you
know it's tiring everyone's just sitting
there doing the same thing over and over
again and um it was the end of that day
and I was like there was this moment
where we had we had to set up for
another scene but it was super easy so
every single actor and all of our
background performers just all happen to
be there with time to spare and I was
like you guys if there was ever a time
to you dance it would be now and so um
he and Ashley Ashley who plays at
Matthew was it really okay sure like
what's the dance and I was just like
okay and I just like made up this dance
and Lizzy was sitting right there and
she's like you I should do it like the
three of you should do it I was like
okay and then I taught them in like two
seconds cause it was super simple dance
and then I was like and then Lizzy look
we may be like I'll do it too or like
you know ting you know like I was like I
feel like we should all do it
so then me Ashley and Bahia go out the
background are all like in their
formation waiting for the scene to start
and we just quickly like we each take a
line and teach that line the dance and
they learn in two seconds Wow um Maddie
comes running along I don't know where
she was probably like so we just like
did this we're just like gonna do this
dance okay and she's like okay and I
teach her and then Mike Barker who's the
director who I he's directed the most
episodes and I thought when I say I'm
too comfortable on set I think it's
because when he's around I feel so I'm
just like oh I own this place like this
is my Play
so I'm like Barker we're doing this and
he's like okay fine he's like how do you
want it director and I'm like okay so I
want a camera here and then we'll do a
camera here so we actually had two
different cameras getting the scene and
so we and then I would like and I think
it would be good if we made it seem like
because we were about to shoot this
scene where aunt Lydia just goes around
and really in a scary dark way and then
dismisses each of us one by one and I
was like I feel like it should be that
everyone still and then we'll just do
the dance like how funny would that be
and so then that's what and then it was
insane like we never even practice it
they were like Nina and I also like I
don't want to be that person on things
like wasting everyone's time okay good
because it was like we literally have
one take to do it
everyone everyone like is tired everyone
wants to go home like this isn't the
Alma dance show so I was like okay let's
just try it and we just did it once
everyone did it perfectly and then if we
was just done and we were all and we
were so happy like and then we all just
like he gave us all so much happiness to
do a generous and fun thing on set and
so yeah then once we made that other
people saw like Yvonne and command and
so then they did their own versions of
dances but oh my god you know it all
started that fateful banner again nice
fun thing to do yeah and you're you're
making whoever makes the blooper reel
for season three or you're helping them
do their job so props to you also I was
also wondering too like when you're
talking about these extras that are
around and then like the new cast member
of off math of Matthew do you think
there's like because I was a girl and I
was an extra and I was a handmaid that
day I'd be insanely intimidated by
seeing you and Maddie on set because you
guys have been the show so long you're
so respected like do you feel vibes of
people being nervous around you guys
like oh do we fit in with them like and
like or you guys feel like you're chill
and like everyone kind of just eases up
around you guys
I think that I felt that before where
I'm like oh man I I feel like this was
intimidated or nervous or a couple of
times like so just like hey can we take
a picture with you and it should be nice
it's not you know nervous but I think
that I've just I'm just the type of
person where I want people to feel
comfortable around me so I think that
usually we don't really we all talk a
lot and yeah Gus things and also there's
a lot of background performers on
handmade sales who have been there since
the beginning oh wow
and so yeah and so you see them and
you're like hey how are you woody how
are you doing like oh yeah this is what
we're doing today yeah it's gonna be
Harvey isn't it and you know they're
really really great and a huge reason
why the show is as good as it is is
because of the background performers and
like I think everybody on set
acknowledged is that like I remember
when we finished the very first season
our first ad of that season yelled out
this thank you to our background
performers you have made this show what
it is and I think that they are really
respected on that show so there really
isn't I mean just like any set and
anyone knows they're always is that sort
of um I don't even like the difference
between okay this is this person as a
background for us is this person as an
actor but it isn't as strong on that
show because the background really are
respected in the sense that they they
are really really good and they're also
just there's a nice girls and we're all
kind of the same age and so it's nice to
just I think there definitely is moments
where like you know they're kind of like
intimidated they wouldn't necessarily
talk to all of and also we don't know
all of them personally the way we know
each other personally like you know the
way media Ashley Maddie will be hanging
out and of course when we're all on set
we'll be talking to each other because
we know each other but there's a lot of
background who I've seen so many times
that you're able to guys oh like Ashley
how are you doing blah blah so um I
think that's that's the general vibe
with yeah but yeah with the background
so I I want people to know listening to
shifting gears off hand mades nina kiri
is also a creator a director a writer
she wears many hats she's been doing for
a little bit now blood the webseries
season two recently came out and I see
that it was nominated for outstanding
achievement in writing at NYC web fest
how did that feel being recognized for
something like this it was really really
cool like we I mean blood is such a gift
random ad hoc me and a couple of people
that I get along with really well just
decided to make this thing and so to be
able to go I didn't end up going but Sam
and Eli were at the web best and I was
like oh my god we're up against there's
this show called dreaming wolf black and
is one of my favorite web series and I
would like the fact that were nominated
with this show which is actually you
know has money behind it and is an
incredible show we just felt cool
because for us it was just this random
little thing that we did but yeah that
was that was really cool
I actually funny that you mention that
because this weekend I'm I wrote a short
film that I'm directing this weekend and
it's my first like on my own road it
oh my comedy so last night I had this
nightmare that I got I was like
everything went wrong my first time you
know with blood it's super like we're
all friends we do the road this is like
I'm actually working with actors who are
Union and I write producer and like
actually Colin who shoots Handmaid's
Tale Colin Watkinson he's going to be
shooting it he he's actually stopping in
Toronto to shoot it before he goes back
to LA so it's you know it's a just a
bigger deal so I guess I last night that
all hit me and I was like oh man I'm
really excited about it and I think it's
gonna be cool so I'll keep you posted on
that please do and uh cuz you do all
these things creating writing directing
acting do you have a personal favorite
you like to do out of those no actually
I I really been I think it's
just like a progression and all of it is
great
like some of the roles that I've gotten
to play this year and last year as
opposed to before have been so much more
interesting than anything I've ever done
and I think that is so exciting and then
also getting to write and direct I I
just love I love it I really like doing
all of those things in different
capacities like the first time I did a
read-through for this short I actually
like oh god I was like oh my god and I'm
just get to be like here and work with
these actors were so good right and it
was a really really cool feeling um but
yeah I don't think that there's one that
I would like more okay so another
question kind of like that though is I
feel like I've seen you in horror you do
so much comedy with your webseries and
obviously very serious in Handmaid's
Tale is there a specific genre that
pulls it you the most and that you'd
want to be more involved with no I think
it's between drama and comedy and I was
also gonna ask two leading kind of off
of that I mean you're already living out
your dreams here which is awesome and so
inspirational to other actresses but is
there an ultimate you dream you have of
like when you're having not nightmares
you're actually having good Jules
where do you see yourself like do you
see yourself like this big director or
getting an Oscar like what's the
ultimate dream for Nina Carrie oh well
can I just first say my dreams are in I
dream I dream about like really simple
things okay people and like I was eating
sighs and my dreams are really simple
but my dreams are simple to anybody I
just want to be able to keep working and
I want to I really don't have this like
in terms of I don't know awards or not
award I really don't I really genuinely
love doing this and I think I'm so lucky
to get to do it and I would just hope to
be able to at bigger capacities
continue to raise my life
work in what I'm working in and be able
to just do that I mean that would be
incredible because I think a lot of
people you know aren't able to live off
of a creative career and I've been I've
been able to and I think that's really
really special so I hope to be able to
continue to do that and obviously to be
writing more and directing more and just
kind of see where it goes I I really
don't have a cific goal but I do have
the wish to keep doing all three of
those things to bigger capacity that is
amazing and I have to address the
elephant in the room here your Instagram
bio it says your you go nostalgic now
that's a super mini hatchback that had a
hell of a run until 2008 did you drive
one do you still have one hiding
anywhere
we know I was not referring to that I
know I was referring to a subgroup of
people who were from the former
Yugoslavia who feel nostalgic towards
that country so when I was like when I
was born there it was Yugoslavia that's
where I was born born in Belgrade the
former Yugoslavia and Yugoslavia was
this really cool country because it was
not a part of the Cold War it kind of it
as I'm saying a part of a non-aligned
movement and I think I just I think a
big part of me like anyone who's from a
different country was born in a
different country and I have these like
nostalgic and wow what would it have
been like for me to be she's grown up in
the former Yugoslavia so actually other
than that I thought you're just obsessed
with these batch of attacks I was like
no that's really what changed my bio
it's more its political but no that's
all you know BIOS are supposed to be who
are you really
person's like well that's one thing I've
always been I've always been really
nostalgic of this country that doesn't
exist anymore that my whole family is
from no yeah that's trust me that's an
amazing bio that's that's um that's my
shortcomings that I read that as a
hatchback funny so closing out please
everyone I'm linking in my info on this
video the webseries blood you can watch
it on YouTube it's two seasons or quick
episodes they're great quick wit kind of
reminds me abroad City please hit that
in the info down below make sure to
subscribe to that channel and give it
comments like share it and is there
anything else you want to promote I saw
an IMDB you're gonna be in easy land and
the code can you tell us anything about
these projects yeah easy mind is an
incredible film that I'm really really
excited about it may or may not be at
TIFF this year okay and I'm really
really stoked about it it is actually
it's in the movie I do speak Serbian and
English and soldered to what I just
talked about with me being you're gonna
sell judge um this was literally like
the movie of my dreams
I woke a because it was really I worked
with this director who I've worked with
before Sonya Kovac and she she's also a
Serbian Canadian and I got to work with
this woman medium that Djokovic who is a
who had kind of this like iconic actress
of my parents age in Serbia and when
they found that I was working as though
they were like oh my god and she was so
incredible and it was just this insanely
cool shoot that we did in Toronto for
this film and and it's a really special
movie I think I think a lot of people
are going to like it the code I actually
shot that last year in in LA and it's
just it's this I all I can say is it's
the size fine
Big Brother II film I'm not sure when
it's going to come out I don't have much
information about it because I think
that
I finished they we're still filming and
doing a lot of coast production but that
one was great too but I am really I'm
mostly really excited about EP land
which will be coming out soon and the
project you mentioned that you're
directing that you're having nightmares
about do you have a timeline of when
that might be coming out like is there's
a whole you know I'd like to submit next
year to a couple festivals so for now I
hopefully will just do it on Sunday and
it will be fine but then I'll see I'll
be I'll be you know editing and
colouring and sound mixing everything
amazing hopefully by the fall and then
and then I'll see where I want to submit
and how I want to submit it to different
festivals but it should be yeah I'll see
oh keep you posted I think it should be
by next year sometime at at least some
sort of screening I can't wait a lot on
the plate for Nina again keep checking
around handmade sale every Wednesday at
midnight it drops in the US
Nina thank you so much for joining me I
hope to have you on again I can't wait
for the hat trick to make it three times
thank you see this it's so nice talking
to you it always is thank you I
appreciate it praise be Nina praise me
and we'll talk soon